i uh would encourage you to join the
discussion on the david pakman show
subreddit we are just so close so close
to 30
000 of our viewers and listeners being
subscribed to the subreddit
find it at davidpakman.com reddit some
interesting posts from this morning
one article uh lets us know
that creationism can be taught as
science
in arkansas classrooms according to what
lawmakers there
are saying and indeed it is horrifying
house bill 1701
has passed the house in arkansas
which will allow the teaching of
creationism
as science for kindergarten
through 12th grade kindergarten through
12th grade not in religious studies
mind you as science it now goes to the
senate
i don't know if it will pass the senate
but this is
very very ugly we talk about education
on the program quite a bit and i point
out
that while it would be great to deal
with some elements of the educational
problems
federally in the united states much of
education is decided at the state level
by state
boards of education state boards of
education
and this is one such example it's
absolutely horrible
we will see what the senate does state
senate in arkansas but at least the
state house
saying yeah creationism that belongs in
science class which is a
horrifying horrifying situation another
post
on the subreddit about the latest police
shooting
says in the army there's no such thing
as an accidental discharge there are
only
negligent discharges saying the army is
very lenient when it comes to mistakes
made in the heat of the moment
but if a soldier failed to do his or her
duty by ensuring they employed the
correct weapon
and that negligence resulted in a death
the soldier would be facing
non-judicial punishment as a bare
minimum but likely a
court martial that soldier supervisor
would also be held accountable
why aren't cops held to the same
standard
well understand as has pointed out in
the thread
that there are ways in which
the military actually has higher
standards than domestic
us-based police forces uh and this often
relates to
uh use of force but yeah as i said um
earlier this week i believe from the
video
that the officer in brooklyn center
minnesota
did not intend to shoot the victim
but that doesn't make it an accident
where we say
let's just walk away from this thing it
was an accident it's
it's negligence when as an officer you
know you
as a police officer you don't need to
know much about
for example uh astrophysics
but you nee you do need to know whether
you've got the taser or the gun
that seems like a fundamental
fundamental part of policing uh she has
been charged now with second-degree
manslaughter and we'll talk about that
more on the bonus show
and see uh what what that is likely
going to look like
one other thing a bread for all user
bread for all
posted does david deepak
pakman the first of the david pakman
show on youtube and elsewhere
actually have a middle name i do not i
do not
and what distinguishes me from the other
david pakman the venture capitalist who
we've had on the show
is uh he has a middle name he has a
middle name and i do not but no
i have no middle name and uh i want to
to be publicly fully known that that is
the case
okay join the discussion whether it's
about police shootings or my middle name
it's all valid
on the subreddit which you can find at
davidpakman.com
r-e-d-d-i-t